After we turned in a cheek swab, do you muscle tests for a specific brand of a particular
supplement that you are wanting to recommend the answers yes?
So let's say I'm recommending a specific brand of curcumin, black's pretend.
And you may come back, while I already have this brand, can I just take this?
I may look at the label and if it's comparable, I may say, yeah, you can probably take that
just fine.
But there are some that I would question, so let's finish a question.
I'm asking because I can get some pharmaceutical grade supplements at wholesale and didn't
know if I'd do it so I could possibly get a brand that was not right for me.
Well, that is true, it may be true, let's say, the thing to do, I think, is just to send
me those things that I could look at them.
There may be some really good supplements.
If you could get a bit wholesale, then I'll say, yeah, I think you could just take that
to, but there may be something that I may say, no, so just ask me those things that would
be the best thing to do.